right just the whole thing we'll say
don't even talk until i [ __ ]
introduce you what do you think tom
cruise for a [ __ ] strictly business
i'm stevie yeah you're strictly dude
no don't do that yeah dude don't do that
yes
no don't do my brother right now man
we got
this dude right here bob's a well god
oh me and bob yeah
we got george we got my girl right here
how long have we been brother
oh i don't know
yeah i don't know and we got um
we got a lot of we got the king rat
right here man we got country
country times usa right we got [ __ ]
the [ __ ] lemur hunter baby yeah
yeah
white knights low thunder right here
[ __ ] thunder bro i'm after that cage
yeah
yeah you know what i'm saying
it's free we got [ __ ] free here man
yeah we got [ __ ]
gauge eyes
we got gao jazz here man we got you're
lucky yo vaughn everybody clap your
hands
aka nothing oh whatever dude i see you
got your boy right here yeah yeah
talk about my boy right here man
the dj from every cruise ship
bingo 7pm
go 7pm do you think you were on a cruise
ship you get laid or no
yeah for sure
the cruise director always gets laid no
yeah no 0.69
in my room
no dude i would never do that yeah i've
never been offered but even if they
offered i'd say no are there comedians
that accept that oh yeah a lot of comics
do cruise ships but it's not like
desperation or they really want to be on
a couch it seems desperate man you think
yeah man i think some people like to be
on cruises some people like
buffets i mean i have a friend that goes
on cruises
oh really he never even goes outside and
looks at the water or anything he just
stays in the boat and just goes to the
buffet because it's 24 hour buffet i
love buffets i love when they have a
honeycomb really yeah they don't have
regular honey they have honeycomb oh
honeycomb
what do you mean is that expensive where
is that yeah hawaii
yeah
[Applause]
where do you think honey comes from bro
i know where honey comes from trees
brother
that's sad bro
we're talking about
that hit a lot of the southern us bro
when theo doesn't know what he's talking
about he closes his eyes
really yeah
you really don't know where you know
where uh you know who makes honey though
right yeah bees man there we go then
that's you know that's we're halfway
there and other animals there's
something else that makes honey what
kind of there's another insect that
they're starting to get honey out of
what is it
i'm not sure i don't know but let me
look at that bears no no no no
bears are taken out of pots
bears they make it too how do you know
they don't make it but sap isn't that
bad on a biscuit if you put sugar with
it you know that's the only thing sap is
like it's kind of like honey but it's
it's definitely a lot more tart yeah and
you can barely chew you wanna know about
tart sap i got something right here in
my mouth
right now oh right in your [ __ ] eyes
bro oh i can't even imagine the petri
dish that surrounds your [ __ ] bulb
but let me ask you something right now
and this is a real question dude
if um
if like people in the this country had a
disease right and they're all what's my
favorite disease no the only and the
only way to cure it is if you suck my
dick would you suck my dick
i'm talking about billions of people bro
what billions people what what do you
mean what well you said like
basically you said would you suck my
dick
into people
i was like
some disease in the country right do you
really have a dick but you have like a
kazoo
yeah would you would you suck it though
to save millions of people's lives or
what
i mean
here's what i would do i wouldn't suck
it yeah
but if uh someone else sucked it you
know and it was late late at night i
might smell their breath really fast
oh you would do that yeah i would hope
that i wouldn't care that would cure
probably 100 people maybe yeah but as
long as i'm one of those hundred then
that's how it means we'll ask you ask
the reverse would i suck your dick for a
[ __ ] for billions yeah what do they
ask me would you suck my dick for a
little for
for 70 80 bucks what
[Laughter]
that's it yeah 70 to 80 bucks save the
world well you're not going to just give
me 80. can you just give me 80. okay
yeah wow yeah
round it up to 100. what about for a
cheat code on uh on that bejeweled game
you play or whatever
what about from mystery levels would you
suck dick from mystery
doctor
yeah you know i have a leaky i have
leaky things in my body i could see that
yeah
you know when i was on the show i would
i did portland friday night and the
second show um what club at the uh
helium how was it it's okay yeah fun and
i was on stage and then i i was doing a
bit and all of a sudden i just [ __ ] my
pants oh yeah have you ever sh in your
pants on stage no i'm [ __ ] my pants
like in a couple of different places but
i've never seen my pants on stage but
you and i i had i stopped the show yeah
oh i went good night and i went back
backstage and then here's the crazy part
it was the first show friday night
because then i took my pants down and
there was a load of [ __ ] in my pants no
warning
no you don't have leaky [ __ ]
oh my yeah and then what happened was um
who cares what happened after that
i was like this is already disgusting
and it's already like here's the thing i
know i'm gonna just guy can i just
finish my story guy yeah you can all
right um
so i could i go to the manager i go the
manager like they manage your [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude no i go grow can you go get
go to the store and get me a modium a.d
what right because you get a second shot
from the show modium id from what the
periodic table
no i'm audio no that's not an element
bro yeah it is no i know i don't look it
down a motivated emoji where does honey
come from huh yeah yeah honey from trees
come from the woods yeah yeah
but uh he um wouldn't do it
yeah oh give me a motion because he's a
[ __ ] adult dude no no how am i gonna
do the second show if i have diarrhea i
don't care wrap your body in something
dude and get out there [ __ ] boy you know
peddle the [ __ ] riddle [ __ ] boy
underwear you gotta get me all that
stuff man oh wow yeah it was a disaster
friday night
you never [ __ ] your pants man
let me think about what happened to me
one time oh i remember one time i got
stuck in a tunnel my car broke down in a
tunnel in uh pittsburgh and i had to
defecate extremely and that's french
actually for [ __ ] yeah yeah and i had to
defecate
and uh so i got in my back seat in my
car and the only like i didn't have any
choice this was like you know it was
like something gotten into my body like
a pink eye had gotten into my stomach
and uh and all the [ __ ] in my body was
coming out of my body yeah it was in
your stomach yeah it was like hey we
need all this [ __ ] out of here
gingivitis once in my stomach yeah you
yeah
yeah your mouth and i got diarrhea from
that too yeah really yeah yeah i know
how it got down there and i had to
defecate into a frisbee out of upside
down frisbee was all i had
be real yeah yeah
and so i'm in this tunnel there are cars
whizzing by here's the crazy thing yeah
extremely hard to poop when cars are
going by 50 60 70 miles an hour and
furious too
yeah furious like and also white people
like it was pittsburgh so it's furious
white people driving by i can
if other people some certain ethnicities
i can [ __ ] easier when they're driving
by honestly you know like if a couple of
brothers are rolling by blasting some
[ __ ] good music i can [ __ ] blow
ass all day into a frisbee
no problem part of you know everything
is everybody's you know everybody seems
like it's more laid back yeah yeah but
angry white dudes you know rolling by
you know six seven well they would
probably call somebody too huh oh they
weren't calling anybody i mean the only
free finger they had they were waving it
out the window
yeah they weren't using it to dial the
phone so you shoot on a frisbee out of
[ __ ] in the open
now the yeah not the top part but the
bottom part a frisbee is basically a cup
basically the size
oh a plate it's a plate a plate well a a
plate is just a cup that's wasted
hang on are you please just a wide wide
wide cup
or you pulled over oh i pulled it yeah i
pulled over the car i think honestly i'd
run out again just [ __ ] on the ground
why did you have to like oh
yeah so it's dark [ __ ] on the [ __ ]
[ __ ] in a tunnel
[ __ ] okay you should be familiar with
tunnels dude why huh because of vietnam
because you're gonna do that [ __ ] again
right now man what's the [ __ ] bro
why are you why are you oh no no dude
you're doing that nom [ __ ] again huh bro
what number you thought that i was
digging tunnels in the ho chi minh trail
and trying to attack you people no i
thought you meant that the fruit juice
the pomegranate fruit juice that's
always in there
palm yeah no
what do you mean tunnels though bro so
anyway i'm in a tunnel i'm in a tunnel
and there's only two lanes going each
way there's no there's nowhere to get
out in a tunnel like in a tunnel you
know
cars are whizzing by yeah and so i had
to get in the back seat and defecate
into this frisbee right and um
and then wait for the cops to come
somebody i i well somebody not somebody
i had just [ __ ] in a frisbee in my car
and
i
needed help yeah
there's a lot of things i didn't learn
from that story
i'll tell you what i didn't learn okay
say something i didn't learn that um a
frizz a cup a cup and a plate are the
same [ __ ] thing they're not the same
thing depends on the aspens on who where
you are
how strong the gravity is in an area how
fresh the cup how recently you made it
how how warm is the clay
the [ __ ] cup is just a plate is just
a wide wide cup the sides can't get
along
a poem that's all it is yeah that's the
truth dude
wow
go beat a plate apart with a hammer and
then tape it together yeah and don't do
a good job
would a bowl be the same as a as a as a
plate go beat a cup apart i'm sorry with
the hammer that's true you flatten it
out maybe they're tape it together
what do you have
you have a [ __ ] plate you got to play
and he [ __ ] won
your muscle yeah dude your lady is not a
muscle you cook
yeah but i know where honey comes from
you know so we both win you guys we both
lose where'd you say honey comes from
what was your honeycomb the woods
yeah in the woods but in honeycomb yeah
right honeycomb yeah where did that come
from you kook you come you want to call
me glucon
i do not
i didn't say it
you guys edited that in there
yes you did and we have it on [ __ ]
factual files dude
okay that's not a real thing factual
styles i like that though actual files
yeah i make words up bro
no isn't there a drawing that's supposed
to happen right now downstairs in the
ship lobby can we [ __ ] get him a job
the buffet is closed yeah
ladies and gentlemen uh the buffet is
closed well we were in hawaii a lot of
people do look like you
like the service people yeah a lot of
filipinos work on the cruise ships you
know there's no even in the hotel they
all just kind of have your like bland
look whoa it's not bland
yeah why did you call me bland theo i
didn't at all i feel like it's kind of
an island mahogany oh
i like that right but if you like worked
at a you know in hawaii i could see it
like an abc's like if you saw me in a
hotel you know working there you'd be
like yeah that guy's weird nobody can
imagine you working first
i think that's the kind of thing that's
so rude that you even say something like
that let me say something right now okay
let me i used to work on a farm
did you know that an ant farm no no
[Laughter]
oh my lord
lord lord lord
are we doing hymns
that's cute
that's cute man no man a real farm man
oh yeah what were you guys growing dude
honey
corn dude oh really heard of corn yeah
yeah i used to work at a farm i used to
work at a farmer's market
i used to wear you just had a pharmacy
are you just saying things that i've
never done no i used to work
construction i used to wait tables i
used to do a lot of jobs did you really
i was a hard worker okay i don't it's
only when showbiz got in my vein
that i haven't really worked one vein i
believe that part
you have one thing
one way in one way out hey upper lip
thin yeah
dude my lips still growing dude unless
lester holt has a very thin upper lip
and he's had a good time oh yeah yeah
yeah he does have
um thank you thank you so much for doing
thanks for having me i love you like
your family i love you you like your
family and i'll do it anytime i live
just up the street i'm in los feliz i
know i've been to your house oh yeah you
live in a castle castle it's uh oh you
know
i ran to matt broner a while back i love
him well i love matt and you know we
hang out and stuff but
before
he i didn't know he was living in my
neighborhood he's not now but he
ah this is a dumb story you know what
i'll tell you off the air and your
listeners can be a little upset
why not just kind of makes he just might
have about that why don't you do this
you tell the everyone knows it's a dumb
story yeah right i'll tell the story
it's cap it off but let me say something
right now it's gonna reflect on you and
your abilities but i want you to do it
anyway tell the story
[Laughter]
no you have to end up with the story all
right so anyway so my anyway so i run
into matt around the corner from my
house and he goes uh yeah go what are
you doing you live here he goes yeah i
live over there where are you and i go
yeah i'm up here around the corner he
goes where we're around that corner yeah
he goes what do you come i go yeah i'm
like a couple of houses up on the thing
and he goes he goes oh are you near
castle wolfenstein
and i said what and he goes there's a
house up there that looks he goes me and
my gal call it castle wolfenstein yeah
because it looks like there's a guy up
there just breeding wolves
he just and i go i think i'm dr
wolfenstein yeah yeah he goes what i go
yeah i think that's that's my house
you're describing it yeah he goes no no
it's [ __ ] thing it looks like
gargamel's [ __ ] castle yeah yeah yeah
the smurfs and then he came over and he
was like what the [ __ ] yeah you live
there master wolfenstein it's a great
you know what i love about your house
though
you can't
go to redfin and find a house like that
that's like there's a it's a one of a
kind house well how the [ __ ] did you
find that castle because it was 2002.
well i
they made castles since [ __ ] the
1700s what are you [ __ ] talking about
i know my house was built in 1612. it
was the earliest property in los angeles
how did you find it though you just
drove by and go i want to live there no
i went to a different place uh
no i yeah i actually i i jumped out of a
uh i i bought a house up the hollywood
hills because i didn't know where the
[ __ ] to live when i decided to buy a
house and uh they said and then i had to
jump out during escrow because there
were some uh structural things i
started a new search i was in los feliz
i was at this one house they said have
you been by this house
and they told me where i said no and i
walked in there and uh
some some things happened that were nice
like they dropped the price a lot the
morning that i walked walked in because
it was very it was very ugly there had
been um there had been many years of of
um
of you know renovations and stuff that
reflected the time period when it was
renovated right so i i you know i i
restored it with a contractor and
designer back to the original original
thing that it was but you know the house
was built in the 1930s and and so that
was the thing but it was also because
the market in 2002 was very different
than it was even the next year in 2003
yeah and so everything exploded and then
we had the you know the economic
collapse of you know 708 so then you
couldn't really get into the these
anyway it was very
it's a great house i was very fortunate
you know i regret even asking you
that's not a really good way to you know
what bobby
i'm going to tell you something you know
i'm going to tell you
it was okay we should end it there yeah
yeah yeah because just like you said you
did some 10-minute podcasts and it
inspired you to move forward yeah
perhaps it even happened anyways thanks
will sasso coming by
everyone clap right now they're not
little for coming by they're not all cut
it off they're not all home runs cut it
off sometimes people just want to what
eddie is
oh i understand brian ortega for killing
it you know someone who does you watch
mma you know someone who does uh brick
work
[ __ ] it he bit he cause it'll improve
the frankie edgar that's gonna bring up
the resale value of your house yeah yeah
it's never a bad idea to put in another
bathroom
you might as well have them come in that
would be a really good thing i mean i've
got peg and groove hardwood that's been
stained at once
sitting underneath it was centered
underneath marble everybody that was a
great hey take a claw hammer take it to
some of your uh right now some of you
some of your floors
you might find some very expensive wood
under there on instagram at tiger bell
amazing woods on twitter at the tiger
belt fine wood or you can email us any
questions at the tiger belly anything
that you think that someone would take
out and put in another house that's what
you're looking for in your property
don't be afraid to spend the money
you're living you know he's good he my
birthday last week he he texted me happy
birthday you didn't but it's fine
did
you and he's spitting my face don't go
lateral on this don't go lateral let's
talk about [ __ ] anything from you but
i give you stuff i know you do you
really do you're a good guy now
didn't i let you go through my water
bottle
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
is it a classy place your restaurant
yeah it's classy
what do you mean
it's it's clean it's clean you're like
you're an investor you're an investor in
that yeah yeah big time is it off of the
strip or where is it off the strip
let's promote it what's it called it's
called joe coy's place
no oh god be real is that what it's
called it's called
yeah oh that's cool yeah that's awesome
so it's it's off the strip it's right by
my mom's place she lives out like out in
summerlin area did you work there it's a
nice area my mom works there she should
really she helps out well she slices
meat oh that's amazing yeah yeah cool
and then i tell her to leave when the
the meats so if you have enough stock
you can go home this is a family-run
establishment my mom does not work there
[ __ ] no why would i why would i have
my mom's slice
at the age of 71. you [ __ ] dick she's
retired okay she walks in like this i'm
sorry marcos i'm sorry free food i
thought she does when her son uh uh i'm
sorry so sorry um i'm gonna stand up
again yep take a stand spin that up all
right
yes there's a place called um what's the
house in little tokyo yeah it's the most
successful [ __ ] shabbos place in l.a
and the parents work that right the guy
that owns it works slices the meat there
yes because he doesn't so i saw anybody
yeah but i'm just telling you when you
said it i'm like okay i could believe
that you [ __ ] no
no
no there's a difference between that
family and mine
you want to know the difference yeah
that guy has to [ __ ] work there
that's his paycheck whoa
my mom's retired you know what i would
[ __ ] [ __ ] you let me see this mom
thanks for giving birth to me and you
know what on your 70th birthday you're
hired
go [ __ ] slice meat i wish you know
what i wish upon you now you know what i
wish upon you only one week at this
comedy class
okay all right no i want you to don't
say that i want you to i'm a nice guy
you really are not i've always loved you
yeah we've always had a banter we've
never had us we don't have a banter no
like a good banter yeah yeah yeah i
always have good banter i'm telling you
i'm telling you that when you yelled at
me in the parking lot yeah
you need to hear that what did i say i
don't remember you said oh you you were
bad you
hi why did you use your ammo
my minecon roll back write it down write
it down guys
i said that no you yelled at me what did
i yell at you for you said you're really
talented and you should you need to
[ __ ]
i forgot how you said it but you're just
kind of like
you just told me to step it up you said
i was basically you're saying i was
being lazy
and i loved it yeah and i was i was i
was
i enjoyed what chelsea gave me i enjoyed
the work that i did on the road like i
dude one thing i'm not is lazy on the
road because i still hand out cards yeah
and i know everyone talks about that
out here in la still that yo one thing i
know about joe coy at the end of every
set he handed out postcards and to this
day i still do that thing right now okay
yeah you did it the right way yeah all
right
you amassed
a fan base a big one yeah and you did
the work on that
i don't even go outside to meet them no
you know that i've seen it i know yeah
and i feel bad about it but people pick
me up because i'm small yeah they pick
you up yeah they pick me up by the
nagging you're funny you know what i
mean and i hate it you know i made my
point it's crazy though because we try
and pick you up and you're heavy
you're heavy
huh
am i fat
i'm just saying
no be real am i fat you're the same
height as my son i can throw my son
across the room
that's all i'm saying
my study or the same exact height yeah
because i'm 50 but i can't throw my son
in how old are you i mean i can't throw
him older you how old are you now
52. are you really know how you're 47
right 40
[ __ ] you
46. you're four oh yeah we're the same
with the same exact same
yeah we were born on the same year too
yeah that's what it is yeah you have any
shows you want to plug nope don't need
to sold out since 2018.
are you really you go out every week
like that every week
yeah yeah yeah yeah you should too
you guys have fun i watch you guys on
this yeah but you know
he hates the rest i hate the wrong why
you should look at it as a bro you're
doing you're living your dream and
people i can't do it i can't wait to
[ __ ] see bobby i hate it because i
don't draw like you do
yeah you do i don't would you enjoy it
more if you if you drew like him oh yeah
could you be making money i don't make a
lot of money on the road i compared to
these guys i don't
and um
he's not just somebody he
you don't travel like when you when he
goes to on when he goes on road gigs he
just stays in the hotel the whole time
probably you and your girlfriend
probably just that's not no no no i see
your snaps i see um historically i
understand they live it up they love
their best number one
it can generate
he's more prolific than i am
in terms of generic
generating material
and number two i just don't know
sometimes i just go
maybe
i don't want to do it i don't know you
know but i do it to make
pay my mortgage
but i don't i've never like made
a lot of compared to these guys a lot of
money nah
i i'm telling you nah yeah i'm thinking
i'm being right i was at nordstrom rack
and i would come see you remember and
you would [ __ ] take me to yeah used
to work at north shore yeah [ __ ]
i wasn't born a standard comedian yeah
we had part-time jobs
we have so you've had so much i worked
at champ yeah because i had a [ __ ]
dream i was chasing i'm not gonna work
at a goddamn post office
yeah but no my point though is that like
if you i'm just saying one night like a
friday night for you two shows yeah it's
probably two to three weeks of me going
on the road no that's 100
i mean we have to talk about it i know
how much you make
oh you do yeah how because everyone
knows i i know the rule i know how much
the pay scales are yeah i'm not saying i
know how much you make yeah but i know i
don't think you can what but i do know
what i'm saying though is this you know
i know i understand that but let me just
say this all right yeah
you know yes you're not making yeah 95
of the door like yes
yeah
that's what i'm saying
and so when you don't when sometimes
i'll go to a market and i don't i don't
draw it hurts my feelings like what am i
doing this for it's depressing
and then you make
not that much money and then you walk
away and it's depressed yeah but those
people that came to see you [ __ ] love
you and they're gonna come back and
they're gonna tell your friends so you
just gotta keep going back yeah but
every time you don't go back that's when
you lose your fans remember when you
yelled at me in the car and said i was
lazy yeah yeah exactly yeah okay by the
way he yelled at me you guys i don't
want you to think i'm making this [ __ ]
up
yeah he yelled at me and i think he was
at
caa where you yelled at me at the agency
yeah i was in the parking lot yeah in
the in the car and that was the last
time i saw him how long ago was that
it's about three years ago yeah that's
the last time i saw him oh i haven't
seen him in three [ __ ] years we've
texted him we've text yeah yeah but but
that was the last time we we talked and
that was a really nice
he kind of threw that in my face but i'm
telling you i kicked it into overdrive
after that man yeah
but that what it was a weird last couple
of times though we met with even like
robert morton that one time at hugo's
restaurant what he what i did you know
remember i'm sober right yeah and he
goes because he's he he used to see me
vape
just tobacco whatever
he always thought it was pot
but he doesn't he doesn't i he knew i
was sober
so he goes try my vape pen at the hugo's
restaurant right yeah so he went to the
bathroom remember yeah and then i took a
couple hits yeah and then
i got high oh [ __ ] yeah and it was like
a weird that was weird yeah and then we
had that thing in the ca and then i just
kind of walked away from the whole thing
yeah
it also i was mad because of the fact
that like
i just know that him and i on tv would
be just a killer still would be oh man
it'd be amazing if we were on tv
but you know it didn't happen and we
tried we really did try i think yeah we
went through i think we tried yes
you cook it yep
yeah yeah it's good isn't it oh so good
bobby let me tell you
nothing better than having a gourmet
meal at the comfort of your own home at
comfort of your own yeah yeah with the
freshest ingredients the freshest
ingredients yeah yeah organic
yeah
does your woman do you guys live
together
yes i don't know yeah she lives with me
and so does she cook uh yeah she just
cooked for me today she did oh amazing
yeah
butternut
i think that butternut squash is that
what it's called yeah yeah soup no it
was uh it was actually in the squash and
she baked it with goat cheese on it and
oh my god yeah it was amazing man
but it's sometimes if it's not amazing
do you say it's important i say it's so
amazing every time yeah every time even
with fitness oh this is so good it's
like [ __ ] that's what i say
yeah yeah
your [ __ ] you you're a great you're
spaghetti bolognese i mean everyone can
cook spaghetti no no no don't play it
don't doubt don't tell me all your [ __ ]
pretty good you guys it's [ __ ] pretty
good
in fact do you put carrots in it no i
don't know [ __ ] your vienna sausage yeah
i put carrots in my you do yeah is it
good that way you're supposed to i put
carrots do you stew it down are you
supposed to yeah carrots
yeah yeah how do you do it just as a
base you mean like a mirepoix wait how
do you stew down carrots you should do
it down with celery and onion to make a
mirepoix but how do you what's
does that mean they boil it they just
stew it down to create like a boiling
base yeah yeah yeah yeah why don't you
do that [ __ ] i do it i know that i
can't get wow i can't get no mirror on
my [ __ ] bell noise but with other
stuff i do
you can't [ __ ] with carrots in my [ __ ]
or what i do with other stuff when i
make you other stuff like the not on and
all that stuff next time you make what
else you make um i make a lot of stuff
for myself because i cook a lot of
filipino dishes and he doesn't really he
doesn't like filipino he doesn't like
good um he doesn't like yeah like i
don't know what it is
cook with a lot of vinegar all the time
so oh yeah maybe he's not into it maybe
you should cook him some like real
down-home filipinos caldereta yeah like
i would love to be lager
i've had dilila wakanda
all right
it's all right you're so angry i'm not
angry
let me say something right you're so
angry that you have one taste
it's like
bulgogi and then it's like without bone
or with bone
in a pot on
fire let me say something right now let
me say something to you no no i'm tired
of you no no i'm [ __ ] on my when i'm
tired of you no i'm tired of you part of
you accusing me of not having taste um i
have a plethora
i have a plethora of tastes yeah tell me
what's your favorite i love it
let's be real that's the taste right
it's about a little child
[ __ ] it get some real i like [ __ ] bad
[ __ ] you man girls [ __ ] you
yeah if there's japanese food i can do
chinese food you grew up with chinese
food right everyone everywhere korean i
was forced to eat because of my parents
i no one ever cooked me filipino food so
in my later days as an adult
it's still foreign to me the flavors
although we go to that barbecue place oh
we had his birthday at the
filipinos
sort of like a barbecue fusion yeah it's
more fusion yeah it's delicious
yeah and just the corn thing that they
have there it's [ __ ] delicious their
version of elote is really good too you
know i um i'm slowly you know i'm slowly
trying to get into vietnamese [ __ ]
i didn't like them at first because you
know you didn't like them who
the one that's the cookie the food oh
the food okay okay the people man that
sounds racist no i love the people
slowly getting into vietnamese but i
didn't really like them
as a people no i love the people the
food yeah yeah the food i love the
people are you kidding me of course you
love the people
they trust the people kidding me yeah
they tried to take you out though didn't
they they didn't try to take me out yeah
do they oh when you were in uh no i said
no i said um
he always uses the word jungle asian i
called he tried to take him down yeah
jungle ages and then next thing i know i
had to go to like
news vietnamese news and apology
like i was like in doing their news i'm
so sorry we're all human being you know
doing that so now he just calls
filipinos jungle asians but then the
filipinos don't care yeah yeah because
he's also half white
no i mean you call gilbert what does
that mean why do you what what are you
trying to do with that because i'll tell
you what i
i'll tell you why yeah okay
it's like when rob schneider says you
don't mean he's a full age you're not
full asian who's not a full asian rob
schneider yeah he's half he's a quarter
who are you yeah so am i so is this one
but i'm not any less filipino because
that's what i subscribed to you're not
less filipino filipino you're less
phillip you're more filipino than him
look we you your lady and i are more
asian than you
i think like the whole korean you
is less asian than yeah half of us
if that makes any sense yeah
maybe you're right i'm just being i'm
being real you are you
i grew up in green valley
you're a banana all right and in green
valley in poway where i
all white people and we had a tennis
court everything it was yeah you were
very yeah yeah i had a country club
tutor you had a tutor yeah
and i just don't know i was waiting for
my hey toby you know you tell people
like hey
you know what i mean and then i would
play hey bobby are you going to play
tennis today yeah parker i'll meet you
out there you know what i mean killer
yeah
but i was at work today and some guy
came up to me and said
george is a pink dick yeah wow
who's are you george yeah i can see that
though that's not even funny to me his
face is pink
so someone at work listens to tiger
belly yeah yeah but he was like a high
up guy yeah so we got to be careful
there are males everywhere moles
everywhere but he goes george is a pink
dick and then i go holy for me i want to
take back the [ __ ] flavor stuff yeah i
take back [ __ ] all that stuff yeah
yeah
don't bleep it but you know man
i retract everything i've said today
yeah
yeah
yeah
everything i've ever said today hey
should we start the show over yeah no i
think let's just start this this is how
i always do it yeah yeah this is amazing
i know yeah i like mixing oh big things
yeah yeah and i like it when it's like
kind of like advised just disheveled
shoveled like all over the place on your
podcast you have a structure you do and
a producer
i have a producer too this phone guy has
a pink dick
no but you know i like it but it's not a
little chaotic you know i love it this
show has been so much fun i know but can
i just say this though how come i
haven't been on yours i've asked you
[ __ ] you have never asked me and
that's you know what i'm going to say
this i swear to god bobby can i tell you
what you said
i tell you what you suffer from roll up
your text messages i'm sure there's
proof of that yeah no because this is a
new phone so it's okay
exactly
let me tell you something yeah should i
tell you something i'm pretty sure your
lady is going to agree with me you ready
yes
bobby will lie and believe his lie yeah
believe it to the to the to the point
where he'll cry like tears and sell it
to you we've talked about it on here he
is a great great liar liar yeah
great liar and he believes his life so
much so
now it's a truth now it's real to him
yeah
it's like oj
it's like oj it's not like og it's like
okay
oj oj honestly thinks he didn't murder
the entire house not like oj it is like
oh geez never kill the white [ __ ] or
the guy that waiter a waiter but i
guarantee you if you did
i would lie about i would lie about it
and you would get away with it yeah
don't incriminate yourself yeah man so
when i tell people i was at pearl harbor
they people i believe that you believe
you were at pearl harbor because
renaissance did the 911 thing
so i've been doing pearl harbor
and people don't very very topical yeah
yeah yeah
jump right down
you were there i was there man i was
sleeping in the bunker
per larva hawaii
and i heard the kamikaze is it coming
down man
and then my black friend who looks like
you'd be good and jittery had a little
[ __ ] machine gun
yeah man
he was a chef and he you know
what
but no i have told people that and i
have lied a lot
i lie about things a lot yeah you're
right but you know what you can show him
a text message yeah he'll fight it proof
exhibit a exhibit b exhibit c and he's
like i did not write that yeah
yeah what yes yeah i could be like bobby
why did you text this to this person and
you're like that's not my phone and he
was like that's not he'll come back i
texted caps
yeah those are lower
is that is that a character diff law
what the way you're speaking yes
no my lying just your teeth missing
i have one tooth missing over here she
said six
and anyone knows your mouth it's her do
i you know i have so many how many teeth
how many teeth he's got like six missing
in the back row come on let's fix this i
can chew fine i could just choose in the
front yeah but you're a public figure i
too fine i chew him with my front smile
and look to the right smile look to the
right now you can't see it i don't know
just do it smaller looks to the right go
yeah we got to fix that
oh my god
yes yeah i'm sorry
because they were like i'm gonna let's
raise money no it's your show i don't
even have the money kickstarter i can
[ __ ] fix it like like every two
thousand dollars we put like a tooth
that says 2 000.
because they were they said that they
were gonna have to drill
like a nail implant
in the thing yeah and then like i'm not
doing that i should get it into the
skull part upper skull upper skull upper
gum
yeah into the bone yes and then they
screw it in is that a jaw can you just
google it you have a computer yeah well
you can use an upper jaw too man that's
your job yeah but he has a computer
that's on you dick okay god they call it
the uh max uh m-a-x-i-l that's what i
was saying maxilla which is that you
serve at your restaurant
maxilla yeah yeah it's moist
ten thousand uh
slices
slice
so i do i do and that's the character
defect i'm gonna change that about
myself yeah
yeah you should do that
no no i'll tell you what you know
you're you're making you are who you are
it makes life more yes his
life motto is lie to win yes
lie to win
and i've been doing that all my life do
you play monopoly with him i don't you
don't how about chess
uh we try to play we try
and he'll cheat are you good
no i'm bad yeah yeah but you know how to
play i
magnus is it magnus yeah it is a genius
genius yeah i can think maybe two moves
ahead
at tops no you don't why because i know
you don't you think one move no and that
move is does the horse go to the left
no this is how far my mind this is the
truth okay i'm not lying here okay you
move your rook right and i go
why did he move that rock yep in my mind
that's the first thought yep
i think he's doing something scandalous
yeah right he's gonna try to trick my
[ __ ] he's trying to capture something
yeah so why did he move that rook
he's trying to get a b rc whatever it
might be i think right yeah and then i
this is as far as i can think
if he takes this i i have to do this
if it takes this i have to do this and
then my mind will stop
yeah right that's two moves though
uh you had me
hello i don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about right now
this [ __ ] [ __ ] head doesn't know who
helen hunt is how do you not know who
helen hunt is you know helen hunt of
course yeah yeah
she was the dad she was a deaf girl that
spoke at sign language
i'm joking twister you dumb twister as
good as it gets as good as i guess just
did beaver i go did you see castaway he
goes i don't know that uh-uh you don't
know that he's 24. i don't give a [ __ ]
let me say this i told you there's kids
out there that don't know who mark
wahlberg was
i i'm being very honest that's that's
why i had to explain secret and roy i
know but not everybody knows man we're
50 bro i know but the thing is he was in
someone's nuts
how long ago could i just 20 years ago
you're in your dad's nuts
you're 24 years ago
splattered most people have still seen
cast away where do you get that nose
your mom or your dad
that's it where'd you get that voice
from your mom
don't get angry
don't get angry don't get mad these are
jokes here's my point at 19 in 19 when i
was in high school people go do you know
who
uh robert redford is that's not my
generation yeah i know who the [ __ ] he
is
he was still relevant when you were in
high school ditching it to shira mufoon
oh god now he gets into the [ __ ] not
forget forget to share yeah that was
stupid
what they said oh how about this orson
welles was not
in my generation okay that i can agree
but he wasn't in anyone
are you kidding me that's the beginning
of film
magazines then yeah but i still knew who
he was yeah because his name was like
like a famous name but you didn't know
who he was
no i did he was no you didn't you didn't
know any of his [ __ ] he was just a
famous and everyone always said orson
bit this [ __ ] [ __ ]
all right film school what do you see
you see he saw citizen kane oh okay see
yeah nice so then okay well then you
know so then you know who i'm gonna give
you a pass on that
helen hunt wasn't citizen kane
yeah yeah
i'm gonna give you a pet i'm sorry i i i
apologize he's in a closet he's nice man
why are you mean to the kid that's in
the in the closet sitting on a medicine
ball
it's [ __ ] humiliating for god's sakes
yeah give them a water next to a lamp
you know being held by a squirrel
you know what the [ __ ] are you
all those clothes you don't even wear
all of those are my girlfriends
you know what you know it's so funny
that you're here because um i want to be
real for a second oh god
why
because i know you're just going to do
something no to where we're not going to
talk for five years
and we're going to be in our 70s
what happened oh man i was gonna say
that um
it's so weird that you and i would meet
at that time and that we would still be
here
doing this it's pretty cool it's pretty
cool
bro you i'm telling you man you you're a
sense of motivation for me like like
you've i've had like you know like when
you have those paths that cross
and then we're we're still on the same
track trying to chase the same dream and
then we pat we cross again
i don't know how many times you cry do
you remember that one time i went to you
at the comedy store and you and you had
me uh
uh you know go up in front of mitzi yeah
you did that for me yeah yeah yeah or
how about that time when uh i was
working at uh nordstrom rack and i was
doing like uh
catering uh for a yacht company oh yeah
and then i was trying to write for you
oh that's right that's right that's
right yeah yeah and then and then you
were feeding me all this food and [ __ ]
and i just thought you were the richest
guy in the world you have a tv yeah yeah
but you know what something that is that
or how about i'm just gonna keep talking
about my point how about when you're in
l uh in vegas and uh and this is the
second time you came and then even the
first time you put me up in your i slept
in your house yeah you slept to my house
but the second time you you told me to
move to l.a yeah and you're like what
are you doing here yeah yeah yeah and
that's that we barely even knew each
other i think that was only two years
into our relationship and then you were
right away you're like what are you
doing here yeah like you need to be in
la are you doing a sean connery thing on
your face or
hold on let's do the inspirational [ __ ]
and then go to the jokes
let the people sitting in the cubicle
that enjoy tiger belly which is very
cute
let them enjoy it yeah you know i mean
let them get motivated as well
okay yeah because they have a goddamn
tiger belly sticker of your girlfriend
and then a little tiny pink dick
on her back i have a little dick that's
fine i have that too do you have a
little dick yeah who cares i'm rich
but anyways
i want you to know that that you are
very inspirational throughout my whole
career yeah but you know what and you
should hear that because i don't think
you hear that enough
but the thing is the truth is this and
you've always told me to do [ __ ] and i
followed i'll tell you the truth bro let
me tell you after you said no i need to
say it because i've been holding it in
for a long time when you told me to move
to l.a and i said no and i remember when
you left you're like
you did that same thing you did when
we're at ca where you just [ __ ]
stormed out and you're mad
and then uh and then you got [ __ ]
premium blend and you got [ __ ] mad
tea i think you got mad tv first and
then premium blender yeah i got a
premium blender and then you got mad tv
that's what it was and that was just i
got a couple other things
you have to mention it but my point is
is this okay
this is that and i told myself i
shouldn't be delay because those would
have been my gigs no but
the thing is is this is that
you've always been
you could always see
it you know what i mean
like when i first saw
i used to say this a lot but i first saw
dalia or people like that they're
intrinsically funny who are just you
know
charismatic and are just funny people on
stage you have joke riders right you
have guys that can write a joke and
that's valid and that's great and
there's a lot of great joke writers and
joke tellers but then you have people
that are just very funny eddie murphy
but him he's like that he's always been
like that joe you've always been
legitimately just a gifted
funny guy
and you're always a nice guy you know
and um
so i mean that's i mean i don't really
remember a lot of these times but i've
always liked you and i've always um
yeah we try to help each other you know
and
so i'm just saying that trying to be
nice and say
that i'm just glad that you're in my
life and um
even though we don't see each other for
a couple of years and whatnot
i know that there's love there
and um
what's your name again i like you
annabelle i like you
annabelle sorry anna but i'll never
forget again i didn't say hi to you
that's bryce hi bryce yeah you don't
have to meet him okay um all right you
guys recording
you do the countdown right yep oh hey
also don't talk until i introduce you
all right oh new area
yeah we're good don't ever [ __ ] do
that again
god damn it dude
it's all good look how cool it is five
four three two one
blast away
[Music]
welcome to
tiger belly
god i am your um
i'm i'm your leader
that's right
i've designated myself as your leader
and i am um i'm pure magic
i have problems i have a lot of
character defects and i'm going through
a little depression but still follow
okay we have a great podcast scheduled
for you we've got um my girlfriend
lila is here that's minnie yeah kalyla
and we got um
georgetown university right there man
georgie
with this ugly orange beard i love it
dude it's very no come on man
it's like wildling
you look like a wildling i've been
trying for it yeah it's a good look
thank you for you and your skin is pure
and your skin is white and i enjoy it
we've got a cameraman the woman
annabelle
old friend
good to see you old friend
we got uh
because the cousin of george bryce
yeah yeah he gives my girlfriend [ __ ]
eyes
bryce i see you man
i know i see you and you're giving your
[ __ ] eyes all right
and we have a very special guest i mean
is this this guess is okay we've had
pretty good guests on the show okay
we've had well we hope you guys we had
jordan peele academy award-winning now
or he's nominated yeah we got we had
stone street on but this one's a really
good one guys we hooked up a good one he
has a netflix special out what's it
called disgraceful i said not to talk
sorry
until i introduced your name and that
was a test
all right i failed
all right it's called disgraceful yeah
and tom segura everybody clap your hands
tom segura
thank you thanks for having me but i
think oh my god why did you want to do
this y'all know what it is because i
just wanted to hang out with you bobby
oh you are
one of the nicest guys i've ever [ __ ]
met ever
you remind me of eric griffin in the
sense that like there's no
showbiz
weirdness eric's an [ __ ] yeah but i
know but he's
he would have been an [ __ ] if he was
a coal miner
oh i mean i love eric
there's nothing nice guys i don't know i
was like i already like this thing yeah
no no
eric griffin would have been an [ __ ]
wherever he is that's who he is right
right so that's what i'm saying yeah
that his assholeness is just who he is
right yeah okay
he's a nice guy that's just who he is
tom segura okay
and before we get into anything i'm
gonna just tell the people how i met him
um how i truly met you and this is how i
truly because i know when i actually
actually met you the very first time
okay well what say that first then the
very first time i met you
would have been like around
uh
2000 four or five something like that
what yeah on the streets of uh melrose
yeah and it was uh after a show at the
improv
and i saw you you're at a car
like a really tall woman um she blonde
yeah that was sarah that was i was
dating sarah she's like six feet tall
yeah yeah yeah yeah i was like look at
this [ __ ]
yeah yeah and then i saw uh you and i
was like oh [ __ ] bobby lee because i
knew you from tv and i
i said something to you and then i like
kind of like jokingly soft-pitched you a
sketch
yeah
yeah i swear yeah yeah what about it
yeah and then you improvised with me
and then you jumped on my back
like you i gave you a piggyback ride you
i literally jumped on your back jumped
on my back oh [ __ ] and i was like i'm
probably gonna be on the show this
weekend
yeah yeah and that's when i first met
you and that okay so i hadn't seen you
between the story that i have yep and
that there was really no i mean a couple
times we like i would say hi yeah but i
didn't really know you know you and then
i would say something you'd be like
that's racist dude right
[Laughter]
right yeah so
i get booked on um the oddball comedy
festival yeah
and i find out that summer of 2016. yes
this beautiful summer of 2016. i
remember it like it was yes a couple
years a couple years ago yes
and i can't i couldn't believe they
asked me to do it but um
so we go i go to the airport and it's
sebastian monoskalko's was at the
airport tom was there i think dan cook
was there
and you know we were supposed to get our
own tickets
so my manager abby juju
she's jewish
she wants to save money so she always
gives me coach
always she's like honey
it's not a big deal there's no
difference
right yeah yeah so
no i remember yeah yeah so then
these guys get first class yeah so i'm
i'm talking to them in the you know you
know
yeah we're giggling in their first class
and they all leave and i'm like now i
blush
and i'm going oh my god i gotta walk by
them
right
and you know what let me say something
walking by i don't know how christ felt
when he was like
you know holding the thing and throwing
rocks but it felt you know similar yeah
i i would assume the only thing i
regretted in that moment yeah was that i
wasn't already better friends with you
because then i would have enjoyed it
you know yeah did you just feel sorry
for him at that point no like i cuz with
a comic you already like they let you
know what kind of person they are so
there's some comics who would have given
off the vibe of like don't make this a
thing yeah and you kind of like if you
can pick up on people's yeah you know
body language and stuff you're like all
right you'd be like but he was playing
into like he was talking about it like
i'm so embarrassed and i was like that's
awesome
you should be yeah yeah you know you're
a piece of [ __ ] go back there yeah
yeah yeah i mean that's what it was yeah
they were like booing did you boo i
think they were booze and then yeah you
told the flight attendant to bring you
stuff yeah go give them this pillow yeah
no you came back and threw a pillow on
me
he took a first-class pillow and he goes
hey use that you know what i mean and it
was just
so embarrassing but then that's when i
knew that he was playful but here's when
i knew that i really liked him and that
he was a good guy is is that
apparently we were supposed to arrange
our own rides
from the airport we were in austin yeah
to the hotel right
and everyone got off the plane first
class you know when your friends are in
first class and you're in coach you
would think that they would wait for you
to deplane wasn't ally on the flight too
yeah yeah right
no one did straight into their limos
they went right into their limos that
they their people set up i don't have a
limo enough i don't know how i'm going i
don't even know where i'm staying all
right
so i'm like walking i don't see anybody
and i walk outside
and i see tom standing there with his
limo driver
and he says i just assumed that
you don't have a ride
and i go correct that's correct
i'll give you a ride to the hotel
who [ __ ] i don't know who i'm about to
cry who the [ __ ] does that
i mean
no let me get who does that
i mean not only
we're not war buddies
we weren't nom together
yeah i wish i was you know
but um i don't know him that much i
don't know him and he does that that's
[ __ ] dope bro
like i i would probably hurt somebody
for you thanks buddy you're welcome
wonderful guy
do you know what i thought i remembered
though tell me if i'm wrong about this
yeah i did make the assumption you
didn't have the car and i waited yeah
didn't you
come down and go like
oh like where's my car
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he's like
is my guy here
did you book a guy yeah yeah no yeah
yeah i was like that you don't have a
guy oh i i i mean
a normal comedian would have fired his
[ __ ] people for no dude they just no
it's no they they hung me out to dry
then we had a good talk on the way we
did and then we took uh we took another
car well we went to the shows austin was
a fun show that was fun show yeah and
then we went out to dinner afterwards
yeah we did that
bought us
yes like i was like i'm your only client
there's like six comics there yeah and i
was like do you think you're going to
sign all these guys right now
from buying them
yeah ally was there i remember ali was
at the dinner who else
wasn't jermaine fowler
he's great he's great he's doing great
on that donut show yep um yeah i think
it was us yeah it was us it was fun man
that was a really fun time
yeah it was fun and um
you know
it was good to see dane two and
sebastian and those guys but you knew
who i really bonded also with with jeff
ross yeah he's a sweet guy too oh my god
i know him i mean i met him on that too
you know he did i didn't really i'd said
hello before yeah yeah that's the
longest conversations i'd had was on
that thing yeah i think it would have
been real if it had that was like people
don't know that tour you know they
canceled a bunch of dates it bombed yeah
but
if they had had like a superstar
headlining it and it had been a success
we would have all been traveling
together probably for every show and i
think that would have been like super
boring yeah that would have been really
fun yeah it didn't seem bounding it felt
like the end of something yeah i'm never
in the beginning of something
like mad tv i was not in the beginning i
was at the great run and
yeah the last bad years but how many
years were you on eight years of the bad
year [ __ ] end of a run eight years
well the show was on for 14 years
so you're over half of it yeah yeah
about the end
what 8 out of 14 is like more left of it
yeah yeah well how'd you guys meet how
did you get i know you've done this
story before but so my i have contact
like how did you meet we met when tinder
first emerged no
yeah you guys met on tinder yeah it was
my first and only date out of tinder
what yeah
and i just want to [ __ ] run
wait what what you know i was on tinder
to [ __ ] run oh i thought you meant
you wanted a [ __ ] run from me yeah so
i thought you meant too no [ __ ]
this is awesome oh yeah
hit it and split what's the terminology
so when you saw her
when you saw her you swipe i don't even
know which way you swipe right right you
swipe right but that's like that how
does how is the how does the dm'ing go
like you guys are well yeah i have a
trick to it well he had been
you know going on several dates at this
point okay i had just gotten the app i
think i met him like my first week
yeah what i do is this i act like i
don't know how to use it
oh really yes you're like
yeah i'll go
hi
right and they'll go what's up and i'll
go hi again
and then they're like what and i'll be
like did you say hi twice yeah to make
it confusing a little bit and cute
and they go is this working
like i just it doesn't work i don't like
your face right now
why that wouldn't work for you
yeah yeah i just do it in a cup she's so
turned on
can i ask you a question yeah
you like the andre agassi look about the
head here's the thing man
the thinner it gets yeah it's good look
no if it's when you're thinner and you
can let it go longer yeah it just looks
thinner so like if you have hair you go
like oh it's just parting and falling
like you gotta if
you if you don't go short you're really
you're not doing yourself anymore
i mean you can't let the wind pick it up
well you do what paulie does and just
get the the thing what is that what does
he do he he what's that the the implants
i can't do it i just can't he's going to
get beard and blood i'm going to get
beard in plants
really
stop stop
i'm serious why would you laugh like
that tell me what you're so i understand
what are you planning on doing getting
beard implants which is like a hair
transplant you hear it don't grow here
are you serious
yeah that's good i looked it up how much
is it is where to go is it a lot 6500
that's not bad at all and would be
like everywhere now can i just say this
yeah
just don't tell people that i'm getting
it done i know i'm saying it on this
podcast i understand that but comics
don't listen to this
so when i have a full-on beard
i want to show up and have people go oh
yeah he naturally could do that you hear
anywhere else
not much what no like maybe two in his
leg
yeah they take the hair from the back of
your neck
and they they put it under your face and
then you shave it apparently
and then you just let it grow wild i
wanna look but you gotta make sure it go
it goes everywhere right yeah i'm not
gonna do blotchy like i'm in [ __ ]
that's what i thought you were talking
about
chernobyl i'm not gonna do the chernobyl
thing i'm gonna that's pretty wild dude
i've never heard of that when it it
people get it
i looked it up on the internet is it
popular amongst asians yes okay yeah
because we can't do like i can do this
so what i'm going to try to do is grow
this out
these tips
down here so it does a fu manchu
and really perpetuate that look yeah
so
when is uh when is it when you set up
how soon are you gonna do this well i
figured this um because i manifest
things in my life yep
and so this is what i think i think that
i think the show that i'm on is gonna
stay on a while that's my feeling about
it what's it called splitting up
together
um
it's gonna stay on and then um i'm gonna
reap you know i think that it's gonna go
on for five six years
and i'll just kind of retire afterwards
and i'll disappear for a while
and when i come back i'm going to look
like korean gimli
so we do at the end a thing called
unhelpful advice and basically people
ask us questions and we give them help
what help
you'll see
okay okay on health advice with bobby
kelly and gd lee
uh reading some of these questions i
think there's an overall theme uh
if you can give three pieces of advice
to young people
what would you give from all your wisdom
uh or my wisdom i mean if i'm in career
yeah anyone yeah okay if i'm in korea i
say you know you gotta study when you
are young
because otherwise it's harder to survive
in korea
what do you mean you don't agree with me
what does that mean
you have to study go study yeah okay
yeah okay that's the first part and
uh uh be honest
because honest goes whole your life like
me
and then courage you have to have a hope
and you know things to grow up
i think those are three things very
important to me look at that that's kim
jong-il isn't it yeah yeah oh my god
yeah
pretty good yeah
you are the best at that thank you
thank you i love you i love you
bye-bye
you guys have three uh pieces of advice
he wants to talk about honesty
my advice to you is this
um you got to figure out what you want
to do
what you love doing
right that's good yeah
i like it you know i'm not even [ __ ]
done lady
i said i like your story is the answer
okay go on go but i just [ __ ] stole
it i gotta you know okay then what's the
next
second one
you enjoy you know you enjoyed whatever
you like it yeah or
you like it so you enjoy it which one
which one bobby what come on yeah answer
which one don't don't play dumb come on
get both right yeah both mom okay yeah
yeah okay anyway my best
second one
forget it no no no no no no no no you
honestly forget it no no no no we are
not done yet we're not done yet yeah
yeah yeah all right so what's the
question
okay three pieces of advice the three
pieces of advice is this you love your
parents they're okay
there's a second that's not the second
one you love your brother
the second one you love kleila that's a
four four no special special
it's not even a number it's not even a
number no it's not even though number
yeah yeah yeah it's out of a number the
second thing i would give them is you
have to lie as much as you can to
be lie yeah the opposite of honesty
i know no i believe i i know i told you
not to lie i know but i remember you
but you know we have to lie sometimes
why lie
okay and that's what i'm [ __ ] saying
that's what i'm [ __ ] saying mom about
white lies we're we still lie don't say
[ __ ] things
okay
we we need it yeah because when you look
at an ugly person or you are ugly you
can not say that no you have to tell
your good looking you know
that's a lie
right
so just look at george right now and go
you're very good looking no uh i say
you're sexy you think he's handsome
you're sexy
oh yeah in korea he's sexy
in korea yeah in korea korean is a
little different
in america
good looking american
yeah yeah yeah so he has a lot of
competition
oh yeah
[Music]
he gotta try really hard you know
sorry
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's all i wanted out of you this
whole night it's a good idea is that one
thing yeah yeah you're right honesty is
the real lie
if i like people yeah i like them before
i don't like people
nothing i don't say nothing nothing yeah
yeah smile yeah i smile
yeah but you've never seen anything like
it happening no inside inside
[Laughter]
i'm sorry for exposing you for so many
ugly people that's okay it's okay all
right you're welcome
he's good looking one
okay you survivor he's a survivor
survivor yeah thank you oh well that was
um wow
we could have done more i'm sorry i
cannot come every week
i know but no first thing that's not the
last time yeah it won't be the last it
won't be the last
it's the beginning
beginning
what beginnings
i'm going home tomorrow i know you're
gonna go home tomorrow and never gonna
but you will do it again you will do it
again no i'm gonna come tuesday yeah
yeah you're gonna leave and come back
tuesday to sunday yeah skip monday ah
smart you know
smart ass anyway
[Laughter]
i'm um i'm sorry what we went through
but you know what mom i think a
this was
a good beginning
and um maybe some more down the road who
knows but
uh i feel great about it and i'm so glad
that you could fill in and bobby loves
me i love you so much mom and um
you know you beat out rob schneider he
gave me money
i love him
mama loves money so give my mom a round
of applause and tell her give her the
love we love you
she doesn't have she doesn't have any
handles
you don't you you don't have a handy you
don't have instagram or anything like
that do you well no instagram oh yeah
yeah okay what is it it's okay what is
it instagram
like social media i only have a facebook
facebook facebook you know my facebook
all the actors there you know
all over already yeah yeah yeah good
looking what is it with you the looks
lately because everyone's good looking i
gave you a little i'm not good-looking
i know but you know that i'm not right
you are
did you see your high school picture oh
very handsome you look like an actor i
do right yeah you ruined yourself
no you gain weight that's not my fault
right is he right i'm sorry
right crazy
this is crazy you would say that no he's
like a high high pitcher he looks like
elvis presley but now i don't look like
that i [ __ ] it up
you're korean elvis man yeah korean you
know he got the fact too
[Laughter]
you're late on elvis presley anyway
good stuff mom
anyway she was great give her another
round of applause
i really did love it that was fun i
liked it
we'll be back with some housekeeping
hey guys uh big ups to our sponsors
george wrote that for helping us keep
the lights on ridge wallet brooklyn goat
and mint mobile